[Music]  flip or flop stars Tarek and Christina  el Moussa are keeping things cordial  following their split Christina shared  this cute clip of her in taric's  one-year old sign up Braden on Instagram  she captioned the video even on my  roughest days he always brings a smile  to my face and she tagged tarik  he's also been posting pics and videos  of the kids on Instagram captioning this  one it's been a crazy few days but we  love our kids so much  [Applause]  Tarek and Christina announced they were  separating not divorcing with a joint  statement last week later revealing they  will continue to work together on their  HGTV show we're able to work together  because we're best friends we love what  we do we love each other  [Music]